[Música]
en el centro de overnie algunos alumnos
de primaria van a tratar de hacer latir
el corazón de este volcán
[Música]
Hay que hacerlo suavemente Porque si
saltamos muy fuerte Qué puede pasar
despertamos el volcán Sí sí Y si
despertamos el volcán se vuelve
peligroso sería Genial que el volcán se
despertara el espectáculo Sería lindo
abandonaron su región de burdeos para
descubrir los misterios de la cadena
montañosa de los puy del magma de las
nubes ardientes algo que llama la
atención de estos alumnos y terminan así
cuando descubren al revés desde el fondo
del volcán la curva Perfecta de este
cráter
listo podrán regresar normalmente una
semana de clase verde en el corazón de
los volcanes de overnia
es un cráter enorme y nosotros en el
medio somos muy pequeños temen que haya
lava que salga no está dormido hay un
chance sobre mil de que la lava salga
porque está apagado por lo tanto tenemos
tiempo de subir y salir del volcán
crees que el volcán aún pueda explotar
ni miedo un poco
todos somos un poco niños el universo de
los volcanes es maravilloso incluso para
los adultos porque conduce a la
formación de la tierra y al nacimiento
del mundo a todo eso tierra Misteriosa
que cuenta con no menos de 80 volcanes
alineados en el corazón del macizo
central un teatro geológico que atrae
cada año a cientos de miles de turistas
y fascina también a los científicos
para una vista de 360 grados Hay que
seguir al geólogo Olivier toma el tren
eléctrico para llegar a la Cumbre del
pui de Don y sus turbulencias a más de
1.400 metros los científicos siguen
sintiendo mucha curiosidad por los
volcanes porque en las entrañas de la
tierra el peligro acecha
aún hay 30 40 50 o 60 kilómetros de
profundidad masas calientes importantes
probablemente magma y dichos magmas
podrían subir a la superficie y generar
erupciones volcánicas lo que no sabemos
es cuando tendrá lugar Podría tener
lugar mañana en 10 años en 100 años en
mil años aún viven están dormidos
descansan pero no están muertos
algo que no les preocupa a las 90 vacas
lecheras de patrice Shazam al contrario
en este mismo suelo volcánico que hace
feliz a su bato y constituye la riqueza
de su queso las praderas han
desarrollado múltiples aromas regaliz
genciana hinojo de los alpes tantas
variedades que se encuentran en los
Sabores de Susan
si tomas la cantidad de especies una dos
tres cuatro cinco seis este no lo había
contado Solo que hay seis especies
diferentes es la tierra de los volcanes
que trae plantas específicas a este
territorio Pero todas tienen su utilidad
y es lo que le da una especificidad a
nuestro queso
[Música]
es la hora del ordeño y para que la
leche mantenga todos los aromas de estos
pastizales volcánicos papeles instaló su
remolque en altura
vamos a Guatemala Ella es la más calmada
una sala de ordeño ambulante en el
corazón del campo las vacas perciben el
pasto Y nosotros a las vacas Siempre es
así siempre y son numerosos los que
ordeñan así en plena montaña
en el sector DEA Somos unos 30 de 200 de
200 productores granjeros
volcanes que alimentan a los animales y
proveen también un excelente material de
construcción la piedra de volbik sirvió
para construir la catedral de cría como
un ferrant es lava petrificada que
monjes extrajeron de la tierra en el
siglo 13 con mucho esfuerzo
actualmente esta piedra sigue siendo
tendencia una empresa de la región
dirigida por un joven artesano decidió
trabajar este material con esmalte
[Música]
para hacer objetos decorativos al estilo
contemporáneo
aquí estamos bien aquí perfecto Yo sigo
siendo como un niño de todas formas el
crecimiento en el horno para mí siempre
ha sido importante con el calor que sale
a 130 grados aquí hay un pequeño defecto
por corregir
no es enorme pero vamos a cocinar un
poco más de todas formas la lava no se
domestica fácilmente es una roca que fue
torturada desde el inicio y mantiene ese
espíritu
es cierto que algunos días nos crea
algunos problemas
creaciones vendidas hasta por varios
miles de euros en Australia Japón o
Estados Unidos la cadena montañosa de
los pui clasificada en el patrimonio
Mundial de la UNESCO desde 2018 es ahora
una marca que se exporta es una carta
adicional explicándoles que actualmente
podemos proponerles lava esmaltada y que
proviene del patrimonio Mundial de la
UNESCO de auneria de Francia
95 mil años tras su aparición los
volcanes de la cadena montañosa de los
pui constituyen actualmente la riqueza
del patrimonio de obernia Ojalá sigan
siendo gigantes dormidos durante mucho
tiempo